this week The Washington Post published
a damning report on Washington DC's NFL
team in which 15 women made allegations
of sexual harassment and a toxic
workplace it comes as the team following
years of pressure announced it was going
to end the use of the Redskins name in
Native American imagery for now the new
image is a blank slate with fans across
the league wondering what comes next
yeah the the indigenous American
portrait next to yeah ed O'Hara
remembers his role in rebranding the
Redskins of Ohio's Miami University more
than 20 years ago this was the Redskins
logo we change it to the Red Hawks the
colors didn't change we kept the core
font and the attributes stayed the same
fierce you know determined athletic a
few years earlier his company SME
branding had helped New York's st.
John's University transition from the
red men to the Red Storm what was that
process like changing st. John's at a
time before a lot of places were
changing yeah they were way ahead
it was difficult that took every bit of
two years it was fan involvement it was
research it was name generation it was
logos it was coaches it was one of the
more divisive you know processes I went
through they're never easy but they're
always right because they undid I you
know a pain that was existing in their
community
[Music]
I'm starting here over the next two plus
decades pressure would build on other
sports institutions appropriating
native-american imagery many would
resist like the NFL's franchise in
Washington had until this week give me a
sense where does Washington go now well
I think the first thing was they made
the decision so that's really great news
where they need to go now is to consider
a longer term strategy because they're
an 88 year old story franchise with five
Super Bowls thirty to all of famers they
want to continue that history so they
have to be careful and be diligent and
not only is this a name change but it's
really a community kind of beacon of
doing the right thing eight years ago
O'Hara was hired to help the University
of North Dakota rebrand from the
Fighting Sioux to the fighting Hawks
it's a process that took three years
during that time the school's teams were
nameless they were just und hockey und
football und lacrosse it was it's not
the best situation the NFL season is
scheduled to kick off in two months but
I think you have to be considerate of
getting this right taking your time it's
for the next 88 years this this decision
what is the hardest part of this process
it's the naming and trademarking the
logos are easy why because the challenge
is to a name the opinions to a name we
have been in processes where there are
thousands of names on the consideration
and you just it's just a narrowing down
process do you have to think of things
even how does it sound when fans are
chanting liberation the chants is
important you know we've delimited names
just on the chat it just doesn't work
and I think the biggest one of all is
trademark you know I've seen things
killed at the end I've seen opposition's
that you wouldn't believe
typically a team would run proposals
through major stakeholders from the
league to sponsors and season ticket
holders
they'll test how a logo looks from
inside the stadium on a home television
and nowadays on a smartphone it feels
daunting all the steps you have to go
through if you do it right yeah everyone
seems to have an opinion and some
graphic designers are sharing their mock
ups on line ideas include the Washington
red tails a nod to the Tuskegee Airmen
of World War two the rivals and the Red
Wolves a Native American spirit animal
what most have in common the burgundy
and gold I wouldn't touch the colors
right I mean they are gorgeous they are
unique and I think fans will want some
of the history Domanick remain intact
colors are key says former Raiders CEO
Amy Trask
she once proposed a modest and temporary
uniform change for the silver and black
- team owner Al Davis how about for one
game a year we changed the color of the
pants and match it to the Jersey and you
really would have thought I said to him
what if instead of asking the Sun to
rise and eat I suggest it rise in the
West he loved the passion our fans had
for the logo and the helmet and Raider
brand it was a fumble now a CBS Sports
NFL analyst Trask says while there are
challenges Washington has an opportunity
and should enlist young fans in the
rebranding process there are kids now
who are going to be your season ticket
holders and your fans in decades to come
excite them now as for Washington's new
logo O'Hara says it can be a sign of the
team's values adding that in recent
years logos have become more iconic in
design you don't have to tell the whole
story with the logo has to be clean
simple bold it you have to be able to
have it transcend the marketing mix in
your fan base O'Hara believes that
Washington's decision is an American
moment after all we are a country
founded in protest it's very ironic that
it's the original Americans that we're
changing a name that offended them in in
the country's capital it feels like hell
now for the Redskins franchise probably
but they're doing the right thing and
over time I think everybody will realize
that and accept the change that they're
going to make you know one interesting
thing about the colors they're saying
keep them the burgundy and gold but
there is a large coalition that would
like them change because they say then
it makes it too easy for people to
continue using that old gear that has
the moniker on
the counter-argument being that you want
to own those colors though right and
it's just part of your head move forward
with with that new name and right now it
seems like the betting favorite is red
wolves right now exact all over you
alright